in the heart of Washington at dawn
an American farewell
at the queen Vic
[Music]
British drinks
a fryer it felt oddly fitting
faces reflecting the varying emotions of
the moment emotions which have been felt
well beyond Britain
what did the queen mean mean to you
um I think it's so rare that a leader is
as well respected and beloved as she is
you know or was I should say universally
um day and age you don't find that very
often so it's a
it's sad to see someone uh like that
pass away in today's society where
people are always screaming and shouting
at one another and misbehaving I felt
that
she had the sort of manners that you
wish everyone would have also the sense
of loyalty that she and her family had
during the second world war you know
they could easily have left London or
even left the UK totally and they didn't
speaks to character
sorry
[Music]
on the other side of the world it was
early evening in Perth Australia
and at government house in Canberra in a
nation where the Royal attachment wavers
here they paused
in Hong Kong where the balance of
British identity and Chinese Authority
is Shifting they remembered their
Sovereign and the crown she represented
this was a moment accessible to all on
big screens or in their palms it's
thought the global audience has been as
many as four billion people
in France a Paris Metro station named
after her grandfather for Britain's
support in World War One renamed for the
day
a reminder of History binding Nations
and in The Nepalese Hills at a Buddhist
temple a different culture a different
religion but a reflection again of
History's bound the extraordinary Gurkha
loyalty to the crown endures well beyond
Empire
around the world sometimes despite
history but so often because of it she
was for so many the focal figure
she was unifying just by being
Mark Stone Sky News